[Musica]
wow che figata non posso ancora credere
di aver fatto veramente quel passo che
mi ha permesso di entrare nel panino del
ted è veramente una sensazione strana
essere qui su questo palco ad esser
sincero una sensazione è che fate mar le
mani le gambe sì insomma messo
letteralmente cagando addosso ma a parte
questo è veramente un'emozione forte
essere qui di fronte a tutti voi anche
se virtualmente è un misto tra felicità
e timore ed è la stessa sensazione che
ho provato quel 15 luglio del 2017 in
cui ero lì ero in quella stazione dei
treni pronto a fare lo stesso passo che
ho appena fatto per entrare in questo
pallino rosso quel passo che determina
se rimanere intrappolato nelle proprie
paure crogiolandosi nel rimpianto
da quel giorno in avanti oppure trovare
la propria felicità realizzando il sogno
della propria vita
questo è quello che ho combinato tra il
2007 e il 2019
un giro del mondo senza aerei iniziate
il giorno del mio ventiquattresimo
compleanno ho mollato tutto lavoro amici
famiglia ed ho fatto un salto nel vuoto
partendo dalla piccola stazioncina di
mirandola procedendo verso est sempre
verso est
ho raggiunto quindi prima la russia che
ho attraversato quasi interamente con la
famosissima transiberiana in cui
ovviamente mi sono ubriacati di vodka
perché guai a dire di no rouge che ti
offre la vodka poi la mongolia di
commissioni innamorato sotto ogni
aspetto dal paesaggio alle persone
passando per la sua storia affascinante
poi ancora la cina che mi ha stupito ma
allo stesso tempo messo a dura prova
visto che gli ideogrammi sono piuttosto
difficili da comprendere e rendere gli
spostamenti un po complicati da lì sono
entrato ufficialmente nel sud est
asiatico in cui ha trovato la mia
dimensione grazie alla tranquillità
delle persone e devo ammettere che mi
trasmettevano tranquillità anche in
mezzo a quel caos di motorini ha
proseguito poi raggiungendo l'australia
via nuoto e con grandi bracciate sono
arrivato aperte no scherzo ovviamente
sono arrivati sulla nave container e ne
so quale delle due opzioni sia la più
assurdo ma quest'ultima è vera e questo
sono io sono di quei bestioni di metallo
sono stati nove giorni di navigazione
che mi hanno portato nella terra
australe e devo ammettere che ero
terrorizzata non affrontare questo
viaggio visto che il tratto più lunghi
nacro affrontato per l'unico il momento
credo fosse stato piombino isola d'elba
poi però sono iniziati i primi problemi
di logistica che hanno fatto vacillare
il sogno di continuare senza aerei poi
proseguire verso est e quindi spostarmi
dall'australia agli stati uniti
come avevo programmato ma non è stato
possibile si sono susseguiti parecchi
giorni di ricerca e frustrazione ma alla
fine la soluzione tornare a singapore
sempre gli e nave e poi di nuovo su
questi bestioni di metallo attraversando
tutto il pacifico fino a los angeles in
un mese di traversata si so cosa state
pensando e lo pensavano che ha visto che
più che un mese di traversata è un mese
di isolamento data che a bordo non c'è
nemmeno connessione di internet è
l'unico obiettivo in quei giorni e
cercare di non diventare pazzo ma a
parte gli scherzi è stato uno dei
momenti più belli del viaggio perché è
stato a tutti gli effetti una
disintossicazione dal mondo e da tutti
gli apparecchi elettronici che si creano
confusione ed anzi anche senza che
nemmeno ce ne accorgiamo quel modo lento
di viaggiare in una in realtà in cui si
va sempre più veloci mi ha fatto
comprendere il vero valore delle
distanze rendendo il raggiungimento di
ogni destinazione
una conquista comunque può essere
completamente impazzito sono tornato
sulla terraferma e quindi alla civiltà
ho visitato un po di stati uniti o
meglio un po di california visto che mia
base da paziente non è permesso di
spostarmi molto
di questi americani proseguendo verso
sud poi sei arrivato in messico ma dato
che i tempi a causa di alcuni problemi
accumulati stavano stringendo sono
saltato di nuovo sono nave mercantile
che mi ha portato dritti in colombia
attraverso il canale di panama de liso è
entrato ufficialmente nel sud america in
cui dovuto imparare da zero
lo spagnolo passando quindi per la
colombia appunto in cui ho prestato
volontariato e alla comuna tre bici day
in cui ho visitato la laguna creata
formatasi nel cratere del vulcano kg top
poi ancora però in cui si è realizzato
un altro piccolo sogno bolivia in cui ho
assistito ad uno dei paesaggi più
assurdi mai visti nel salar de uyuni il
deserto di sale poi l'argentina in cui
ho ammirato e le montagne dei 14 colori
e poi le cascate di iguaçu in brasile
deco mi sono imbarcato di nuovo sono il
mercantile che aveva portato dritto in
marocco ormai ad un passo da casa
infine passando attraverso l'europa dopo
esattamente 730 giorni ho chiuso il
cerchio completando così il giro del
mondo e diventando il più giovane
italiano ad aver compiuto appunto un
giro del mondo senza aerei
non fraintendetemi però non è stata di
certo una vacanza piuttosto lo definirei
un viaggio intenso ricco di emozioni si
ma allo stesso tempo di problemi e di
paure e devo ammettere che senza questi
ultimi non sarebbe stato minimamente
così bella ed emozionante questo viaggio
perché alla fine e questa è l'essenza
del viaggio trovassi di fronte alle
avversità e superarle volta per volta
viaggiare è un po come risolvere un cubo
di rubik con lo stesso metodo seppure
ogni volta sembra incastrato in
posizioni irrisolvibili
ovviamente il mio approccio verso le
paure cambiato drasticamente nel corso
di questi due anni
nessuno mi ha dato la forza la
determinazione necessarie per mollare
tutto ed affrontarle
partendo per questa avventura ho
iniziato un percorso duro e complesso
non ero e non sono supereroi vivevo
quindi una vita normale come quella di
qualsiasi altro ragazzo avevo un lavoro
le mie passioni
e tutto ciò di cui avevo bisogno meglio
avevo tutto ciò che normalmente si pensa
sia necessario per essere felice
eppure non lo era
mi sentivo spesso inadeguato fuori luogo
e la domanda sei felice
beh spesso evitava di rispondere mi
sentivo persino in grato per tutto il
comfort che avevo delle volte mi
chiedevo cosa che mancasse eppure è qui
che forse è nato il problema il confort
quel tanto nominato confort sentivo di
dover vivere dell'essenziale per
riuscire a comprendere realmente me
stesso e capire cosa esattamente
felicità significasse per me
spesso ci si sbaglia pensando che ci
siano a formula uguale per tutti per
essere felice quando invece il bello
dell'umanità è la diversità e proprio
per questo differente per ognuno di noi
e di allora se aveva un sogno che mi
avrebbe portato ad un passo verso la mia
felicità
avevo quindi una parte della mia formula
personale era un sogno è talmente grande
e pro che mi spaventava persino di
raccontarle miei amici
ma vi immaginate la conversazione chi è
che mi prenderebbe sul serio ma non mi
creava assolutamente nessuno ed ero
circondato quindi da scetticismo un po
per l'età è un po perché sembrava che
questa idea fosse stata campata per aria
all'improvviso ma non mi importava non
ho lasciato che questi ostacoli mi
influenzassero ma anzi mi rafforzassero
e più mi si diceva che era impossibile
più diventano forte non posso negare che
ero spaventato aveva una paura folle
anche solo a pensare che lo sto per fare
ma la cosa di cui avevo più paura in
assoluto
erano i rimpianti ero terrorizzato a
morte
nell'immaginare mia 30 anni senza
nemmeno ricordare cosa avevo fatto in
quel periodo
e sono stati proprio è stato proprio la
cura degli impianti stessi che mi ha
dato quella forza e quella spinta in più
che mi ha fatto fare quel passo che ha
dato vita ad una delle idee più folli
che ebbe mai avuto nella mia vita
quel passo che avrebbe portato in
mongolia in uno dei paesi che conoscevo
di meno ma che proprio per questo mi
affascinava di più mi trovavo lì dunque
dopo solo un mese di viaggio ma con un
budget che non perché non mi permetteva
di fare nessuna attività perché per
quanto possa sembrare strano
i prezzi di turi mongole sono veramente
alle stelle e date l'impossibilità di
muoversi autonomamente sia quasi
costretti ad affidarsi sono guida locale
è stato uno dei primissimi problemi che
mi si è presentato durante il viaggio
ed in quel momento sembrava veramente
insormontabile
ho passato due giorni interi
scandagliare internet da ogni possibile
soluzione che potesse avvicinarsi al ad
un prezzo che potevo permettermi ma
niente sembrava farò il caso mio ero
pronto ad andarmene quindi rinunciando a
tutto questo poi però il caso ha deciso
di dare meno opportunità pazzesca
grazie ad un incontro fortuito con un
ragazzo romano incontrato nell'ostello
in cui alloggiava io vi giuro che non so
quante probabilità ci fossero di
incontrare una persona che aveva deciso
di mollare tutto per fare il giro del
mondo di due anni proprio come me
partite esattamente lo stesso giorno
eppure è successo ed è successo anche
che quello stesso ragazzo avesse da un
tour in programma ed è che dopo
solamente due chiacchiere mi offrisse di
unirmi a lui senza nemmeno chiedermi di
dividere le spese un'offerta folle
ricevuto così su due piedi da uno
sconosciuto ma che sarebbe stata però
l'unica occasione per visitare la tanto
attesa mongolia stavo per accettare
quando però i primi dubbi hanno iniziato
a farsi avanti
ho iniziato a pensare che sarebbe stato
da fogli affidarsi
sono sconosciuto per dieci giorni in
mezzo al nulla
e poi perché avrebbe dovuto film into
senza nemmeno voler dividere le spese la
realtà era che non mi fidavo perché
abbiamo perso fiducia nel prossimo che
questo altruismo mi spaventavo a tal
punto dall essere ad un passo da
rifiutare questa incredibile offerta
poi però ho deciso di mettere da parte
tutte le paure e di fare quel passo
avanti abbandonandomi la fiducia
incondizionata delle persone scoprendo
che quello stesso sconosciuto è
diventato ad oggi una delle emergenze
più forti che abbia e che proprio grazie
con la dimostrazione di fiducia
reciproca
abbiamo vissuto entrambi una delle
esperienze più belle di sempre in cui il
popolo mongolo si è regalato lezioni di
altruismo che non dimenticheremo mai
perché appunto essendo il paese meno
popolato del mondo non ci sono strutture
dovevamo quindi in mezzo alle vallate a
casa dei nomadi o meglio nelle tende
gher così chiamate queste tende
circolari e proprio perché questo popolo
è nomade e quindi abituato ad aiutarsi
reciprocamente non serviva nemmeno
chiedere ospitalità che erano appena ti
avvicinavi alla porta per bussare vedevi
capi famiglie che danzavano fuori mobile
bambini per farti spazio ed ospitarti
decapitato poi di trovarmi in cina e di
dover fare i conti con le mie
insicurezze era finalmente arrivata
nella capitale a pechino da dove per chi
non lo sapesse è facilmente
raggiungibile
la muraglia cinese ed io li avevo un
sogno nel sogno aveva un desiderio sorto
ancora prima che l'idea del giro del
mondo mi stuzzica se la mente è nato
dopo la lettura del libro di matteo
pennacchio in cui raccontava di aver
dormito su una di quelle torre di
vedetta appunto sulla muraglia cinese
sotto uno dei cieli stellati più belli
mai visti
addio quindi era ad un passo da
realizzare questo mio piccolo sogno ma
non essendo un'attività e
dell'escursione è permessa
non si trovano informazioni ed è
difficilissimo organizzare
l'esplorazione iniziavo ad essere
insicuro sulla fattibilità dell'impresa
ma ho deciso di nuovo di fare quel passo
oltre le mie sicurezze e con tanta
determinazione sono usciti trovare tutte
le informazioni necessarie per
organizzare il tutto
sono partito con uno zaino un po d'acqua
e la felicità che mi diceva pressione
dalle orecchie e dopo un tracking
sfiancante di tre ore in cui c'era
persino bisogno di arrampicarsi in
alcuni punti sono arrivato lì su quella
della torre di vedetta piena di storia
aspettando il calar del sole poi sono
arrivate le stelle e con le lacrime agli
occhi o realizzati in quell'istante di
aver vissuto una delle esperienze più
gratificanti della mia vita
scusate ma non ho nessuna foto della
muraglia cinese sotto un tappeto di
stelle ma forse immaginarsela è ancora
più bello non sono però stato sempre io
a fare quel passo avanti ovviamente o
terrorizzato chiunque volesse bene
quando deciso ufficialmente di partire
per il giro del mondo erano paure
dettate ovviamente dalla dall'ignoto e
dei pregiudizi e sembrava che ognuno
dovessi mettermi allerta su paesi che
nemmeno e avevano visitato di persona ai
pericolosi di qua ai pericolosi la bla
bla bla alle solite cose ma niente di
tutto ciò mi scalfiva o meglio un po di
carrello mi veniva ma ero conscio che
non si può parlare solamente per sentito
dire ma anzi bisogna vivere un luogo di
persona per dare anche solo un minimo di
testimonianza la mente strada gene e
come potete immaginare ha vinto su tutto
e tutti e testuali parole di mia madre
si è preso per mano quando sei partito e
attraverso il tuo viaggio aiab tutto una
dopo l'altra tutte le paure apparenti
che avevamo
sono stati i miei cari quindi a fare
quel passo avanti oltre i pregiudizi
venendomi a trovare per ben due volte la
prima a bangkok in cui per tutta una
serie di eventi mia mamma e mia nonna
se non volete trovarmi nella capitale
thailandese in cui si sono immerse per
la prima volta nella vita asiatica
innamorandosene follemente proprio come
me
pensate che mia nonna non aveva nemmeno
il passaporto e non era neanche mai
stata fuori dall'europa invece qui è su
youtube tuc la seconda volta invece si è
realizzato un sogno che da troppo tempo
giaceva nel cassetto un sogno che
avevano i miei genitori fin dal loro
giovinezza
farò un viaggio on the road tra i parchi
californiani sempre per una coincidenza
di eventi ci siamo trovati a san
francisco in california e con un camper
a noleggio
abbiamo esplorato per nove giorni le
bellezze che questa terra ha da offrirci
[Musica]
la paura quindi non è un nemico ma una
preziosa risorsa
e allora abbiate il coraggio di avere
paura
[Applauso]